An seiner Hochzeit
habe ich zu seinem Charakter
ein Horoskop zitiert.
"Er ist ein eigenwilliges Kind
und fügt sich nicht gern."
"Man darf ihm nichts befehlen."
"Wenn man ihn nach seinem Beruf
fragt, ist die Antwort klar:
'Ich will Chef sein.'"
"Seine Dominanzkraft ist stark."
"Er entwickelt einen Arbeits-
fanatismus und ist ehrgeizig."
Das kann ich nicht verneinen.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich mich
darin nicht sehen würde.
Es ist eigentlich noch hübsch.
Dies ist die Geschichte eines Mannes,
der sein Leben auf den Kopf stellt.
Christian Jott Jenny,
hier mit seiner Mutter, ist Musiker,
Gründer des Amts für Ideen
und des Jazzfestivals St. Moritz.
Jetzt will er neuer Gemeindepräsident
von St. Moritz werden.
Ich glaube, dass ich
auch in einem Krisengebiet gut wäre.
Wenn ich etwas anderes tun würde,
dann wäre es etwas
wie Medecins Sans Frontieres.
Dummerweise bin ich weder Mediziner
noch diensttauglich.
Deshalb gehe ich
nach St. Moritz Sans Frontieres.
St. Moritz ist aber
kein Krisengebiet, oder?
Doch, natürlich ist es das.
Einfach auf einem anderen Niveau.
Eigentlich gehört
Christian Jennys Leben der Musik.
Er ist ehemaliger Zürcher Sängerknabe
und hat sich in Berlin
zum Operntenor ausgebildet.
Ich weiss es nicht. Es kann
auch sein, dass sie schnell sind.
Jenny macht sich bereit
für einen Auftritt als Leo Wundergut,
eine seiner vielen Rollen
auf der Bühne.
Ich habe eine Art Figur gesucht,
einen liebenswürdigen Hofnarr,
der auf hohem Niveau
die Wahrheit aussprechen
und den Leuten klipp und klar
ins Gesicht sagen kann,
wie es um sie steht.
Das geht wirklich viel besser
mit einer Kunstfigur.
Als Privatperson
kommt das nicht so gut an.
# Wir brauchen keine Millionen,
uns fehlt kein Pfennig zum Glück.
# Wir brauchen weiter nichts als nur:
- Musik.
Musik.
Jenny ist Gast beim Schweizerischen
Hauseigentümerverband,
wo der Direktor pensioniert wird.
Wir verabschieden uns heute ...
* Lachen *
... von einem Menschen, ...
... der im HEV Schweiz alles ...
... respektive vieles, ...
also einiges ...
* Lachen *
... sprich das eine oder das andere
gewissermassen ...
... auch zu einem kleinen Teil
fast ein bisschen geprägt hat.
In Jennys Leben
jagt ein Termin den nächsten.
Wo müssen wir da rauf?
Kaum ist der Auftritt zu Ende,
eilen die Musiker an den Flughafen
zum nächsten Termin in Hamburg.
Nun müssen Sie schnell packen
und gleich weiter.
Ja, so ist es.
Ich habe das Gefühl, Sie mögen das.
Sonst wird es Ihnen langweilig.
Ja, wenn zu viel Zeit vorhanden ist,
bin ich nicht konzentriert
und nicht bei der Sache.
Am besten bei der Sache bin ich,
wenn die Zeit knapp ist
und alles Schlag auf Schlag
gehen muss.
Das ist schon fast
ein bisschen manisch:
Beim Mittagessen immer
den Computer auf den Knien.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Da habe ich gearbeitet, weil ich
die neuesten Infos wissen wollte
für die Moderationen heute.
Das ist nicht manisch. Ich habe
auch keine E-Mails gecheckt.
Ich habe geschaut,
ob irgendetwas geschehen ist,
das alle 1'500 Leute auf ihrem Handy
auch schon angeschaut haben.
Denn so kann man
live darauf eingehen.
Die Sache lebt ja durch Aktualität
und Spontanität.
Man muss immer wissen: Es ist
eine alte Figur mit alten Schlagern,
mit alter Musik, aber topaktuell.
Deshalb muss ich wissen, was läuft.
Darf ich dir die Jacke geben?
Es ist fast ein bisschen warm.
Adieu!
Selber Musik zu machen,
war Jenny aber bald zu wenig.
Und so gründete er vor elf Jahren
sein eigenes Jazzfestival
in St. Moritz.
Dort lebt er temporär im umgebauten
Olympiastadion von Rolf Sachs,
dem Künstler und Sohn
von Gunter Sachs, in einer WG.
Jenny ist geschieden
und Vater zweier Kinder.
Sachs ist nur einer von vielen,
die Jenny als talentierter Netzwerker
für seine Ideen einspannen kann.
Zusammen verpflichten sie
hochkarätige Künstler,
und so hat sich das Festival
in kurzer Zeit
einen exzellenten Ruf geschaffen.
Ich glaube, dass es jetzt
für alle Künstler ein Begriff ist.
Die wollen gerne hierherkommen.
Die wissen, dass sie in die tollste
Landschaft, in einen intimen Rahmen,
in ein familiäres Umfeld kommen,
in dem sie
mit Wärme aufgenommen werden.
Und nicht mit Konzerthallen,
wo alles zack, zack abläuft
und es nur ums Geld geht.
Darum geht's hier nicht.
Wir wollen den Leuten Kultur bieten.
Ah, Grüezi!
Der sog. Dracula Club
ist noch immer das Herz des Festivals
und fasst nur 150 Zuschauer.
... alle am nächsten Tag, wenn
das hier alles abgerissen wird -
also nicht das Haus, aber ...
* Lachen *
Am letzten Konzert dieses Sommers
spielt der deutsche Entertainer
Helge Schneider.
* Schnelle Jazzmusik *
Neben diesen Konzerten
organisiert Jenny weitere in Hotels,
unter freiem Himmel oder im Hallenbad
mit bis zu 3'000 Zuschauern.
Danke vielmals, es war wunderbar.
Ein enormer Aufwand,
ein ständiger Kampf um Bewilligungen
und gegen die langsamen Mühlen
der Politik.
Ciao, alles Gute.
Ciao, vielen Dank.
Zwar versprüht St. Moritz
gegen aussen noch immer viel Glamour,
aber in der Realität
herrscht Stagnation.
Und so kommt Jenny zum Schluss: Er
müsste ganz St. Moritz übernehmen -
mit einer Sprengkandidatur als Par-
teiloser für das Gemeindepräsidium.
Zwei Tage nach Ende des Festivals
übt er die Bekanntgabe seiner
Kandidatur mit Freunden und Beratern.
Wer hinter der Kampagne steckt?
- Ja, wer finanziert Ihre Kampagne?
Äh, EMS-CHEMIE.
Nein, also ...
Falls diese Frage aufkommen würde:
Im Moment ist es so,
dass ich die Kampagne
zu 100 % selber finanziere,
aus eigenem Antrieb.
Das ist mein Investment
in die ganze Geschichte.
Es ist mein privates Geld.
Wollen wir kurz eine Feedbackrunde
zum Gesamtauftritt machen?
Ein bisschen Begeisterung
wäre gut gewesen.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass du da,
wo du unabhängig von deinen Notizen
sprichst, beginnst zu leben.
Deine Stimme beginnt zu leben, du
schaust auch plötzlich die Leute an.
Ich würde nicht mit dem Text
arbeiten. - Gut.
Ich würde den Text
nochmals gut durchschauen,
die Themen nochmals überlegen,
aber am Schluss versuchen,
die eigenen Worte zu finden.
- Okay.
Und ein bisschen Begeisterung,
vielleicht
auch mal noch die Haare waschen.
Grossartig.
Pediküre, Maniküre, Alles-Küre.
Politik ist mühsame Knochenarbeit
in kleinen Schritten.
Das liegt Ihnen doch gar nicht?
Mühsame Knochenarbeit
ist auch das Musikmachen.
Mühsame Knochenarbeit ist auch,
ein Festival aufzubauen,
ein Amt für Ideen zu führen.
Jede Bühnenshow besteht zu 90 % aus
anstrengender Schreibtischarbeit,
aus Proben mit verschiedenen Leuten
usw.
Alles, was so locker vom Hocker
scheint und improvisiert wird,
bedarf einer
verdammt guten Vorbereitung.
Wenn es locker aussehen soll, muss
man wahnsinnig gut vorbereitet sein.
Das ist beim Improvisieren
und auf der Bühne so,
es ist beim Jazz so und vermutlich
ist es auch in der Politik so.
Noch ist alles vertraulich.
Selbst Jennys enge Freunde
sind nicht eingeweiht.
Wie würde sich Rolf Sachs
Jenny rein theoretisch
in der Politik vorstellen?
Die Politik
würde ihn sehr zermürben.
Ich glaube, da geht es uns gleich.
Es ist einfach ...
Obwohl er an und für sich
ja ein Beamter ist ... - Eben.
In der Politik muss man einfach
oft so viele Kompromisse eingehen,
dass man kein richtig gutes,
pures Produkt daraus hervorbringt.
Um das zu machen,
muss man ganz speziell gebaut sein.
Und man muss bereit sein, die
ganze Kontroverse auf sich zu nehmen
und Abstriche zu machen.
Ich glaube,
das würde ihm nicht liegen.
# Der Vogelfänger bin ich ja,
stets lustig, heissa hopsasa.
# Ich Vogelfänger bin bekannt
bei Alt und Jung im ganzen Land.
Als Kind einer linken Musiklehrerin,
wie er sagt,
und eines bürgerlichen Professors
und Obersten
wächst Jenny
mit klassischer Musik und Jazz auf.
Aber Jenny kann mehr als singen.
Schon als Teenager organisiert er
die ersten Jazzkonzerte,
mit 18 ist es bereits eine Reihe
mit Dutzenden von Veranstaltungen.
Wir wollen das alles vorne behalten.
Einfach, dass der Raum
für verschiedenste Dinge offen ist.
Jenny setzt auf verrückte Ideen,
z.B. mit Bäumen in der Kirche
Zürich-Witikon, und paukt sie durch.
* Düstere Blasmusik *
Man sieht jetzt:
Es war realisierbar,
obwohl viele Leute
nicht daran geglaubt hatten.
Es ist einmal mehr eine Bestätigung,
dass man darauf beharren muss,
wenn man eine Idee hat,
und einfach machen muss.
Und nun lässt Jenny
an einer Pressekonferenz
die Bombe in St. Moritz platzen.
Es ist der Tag
seines 40. Geburtstages.
Bei der letzten Wahl
für den Gemeindepräsidenten
hat ein Drittel der Stimmenden
leer eingelegt -
ein Ausdruck von Unzufriedenheit.
Und jetzt soll der Amtierende
nach acht Jahren im Amt
nochmals ohne Gegenkandidaten
durchgewinkt werden.
"So nicht", sagt sich Jenny.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
Zuerst einmal
möchte ich mich bedanken,
dass ich den ersten Kaffee
in meinem zweiten Lebensabschnitt
mit euch allen trinken darf.
Nach dem heutigen Wissen
gibt es zwei Kandidaten
für das Gemeindepräsidium
von St. Moritz.
Einer davon bin ich.
Die Überraschung gelingt.
Als die Journalisten
die Medienkonferenz verlassen,
hängen bereits überall in St. Moritz
grosse Plakate.
Sieben Wochen vor der Wahl
eine neue Ausgangslage.
Ich glaube, er hat einen starken
Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung.
Viele Leute schätzen ihn
und seine Arbeit.
Er ist sehr bekannt.
Aber dass es wirklich reicht,
glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Doch viele fühlen sich von
Jennys keckem Wahlkampf angesprochen.
Darf ich die beiden Herren
auf die Bühne bitten?
Das sind unser Gemeindepräsident ...
Jenny nimmt kein Blatt vor den Mund,
redet, als wäre er
noch immer Leo Wundergut
und erwischt den Amtsinhaber
auf dem falschen Fuss.
Wie viele schlaflose Nächte
hatten Sie seither?
Schlaflose Nächte sind vielleicht
der falsche Ausdruck.
Ich habe mir sicher Gedanken
gemacht, was die Beweggründe sind.
Grundsätzlich ...
Er hat mir die Ferien etwas kaputt-
gemacht, aber das macht nichts.
Christian Jenny, Sie gelten hier
im Ort als ideenreich, als mutig.
Sie geniessen Respekt,
sind ein Motivator.
Sie sind direkt, manchmal arrogant,
neuerdings
auch übermutig und übermütig.
Und Sie sind naiv,
was das politische Leben anbetrifft.
Können Sie sich
in dieser Beschreibung finden?
Tipptopp, das können wir so lassen.
* Lachen *
Gibt es Dinge ...
* Applaus *
Jemand sagte mir, Sie hätten der
"Zürichsee-Zeitung" im letzten Jahr
ein Interview gegeben.
Dort sagten Sie ...
Ich weiss, was kommt.
"St. Moritz ..."
- "... ist am Arsch."
Die Reaktionen
lassen nicht lange auf sich warten.
Vielen Dank, einen schönen Abend,
auf Wiedersehen.
Das politische Establishment
von St. Moritz
schiesst in Leserbriefen
aus allen Rohren gegen Jenny.
Zuvorderst Mario Salis,
Politiker und ehemaliger Hauptmann
der Kantonspolizei.
Als ich hörte,
dass Herr Jenny kandidiert,
war das für mich kein Problem.
Als ich aber die ersten Interviews
in der "Südostschweiz" gelesen habe,
in denen er die St. Moritzer Politik
als Saustall bezeichnete,
als Kinderhort, als Schulzimmer ...
Und v.a. auch,
dass er ein Präsident für die
unter 70-Jährigen werden möchte,
da ging mir die Galle hoch.
So geht es nicht.
Haben Sie keinen Humor?
- Natürlich habe ich Humor.
Aber das ist falscher Humor.
Das verstehe ich nicht als Humor,
sondern als Provokation
zum jetzigen Zustand.
Doch Jenny trifft wunde Punkte.
Projekte für die leer stehende
Reithalle kommen nicht vom Fleck,
Angebote für die Jungen
sind rar geworden,
das letzte Kino ist geschlossen.
Abends herrscht tote Hose
in den Gassen,
die einstige Topdestination
verliert mehr Logiernächte
als die Nachbardörfer.
Jenny kommt unter Beschuss,
alle seine Plakate werden versprayt.
Dann entsteht eine Gegenbewegung,
die Jungen formieren sich
und engagieren sich mit Wahlaktionen.
Doch der aktuelle Gemeindepräsident
macht auch vieles richtig.
Die Finanzen hat er im Griff
und die Steuern sind tief.
Die Gegner begreifen eben nicht,
dass es neben der Kläranlage,
der Gemeindepolizei, der Feuerwehr
und dem öffentlichen Bus
auch noch seelische Nahrung braucht.
Das Problem ist, dass dieses Dorf
seelisch am Aussterben ist.
Das ist das Hauptproblem.
Darum reisen die Leute ab.
Darum kommen sie nicht mehr zurück:
weil es
keine Seelennahrung mehr gibt.
Sieben Wochen
nach Bekanntgabe der Kandidatur:
Sonntagmorgen, der Tag der Wahl.
Seit ein paar Minuten
sind die Urnen geschlossen.
Sie haben Nerven.
Was soll ich sonst tun?
Jenny wartet darauf,
dass die Gemeindekanzlei
den beiden Kandidaten das Ergebnis
der Wahl per SMS mitteilt.
Schau mal, Papa denkt nach.
* Klingelton *
- Zwei. Achtung!
"Lieber Sigi, lieber Christian,
absolutes Mehr: 829."
"Christian: 824, Sigi: 809."
"Es findet
ein zweiter Wahlgang statt."
"Allen noch einen schönen Sonntag."
Nein!
Was geht Ihnen durch den Kopf,
Herr Jenny?
Es nervt mich.
- Ja, das nervt.
Das ist blöd. Nicht gut.
Sigi,
das hätte nicht sein müssen, oder?
Ja, gleich so knapp ...
Trotz 70 % Stimmbeteiligung
will sich Jenny noch nicht freuen.
Und der parteilose Sigi Asprion
ist ernüchtert.
Selbstverständlich.
Ein gewisser Populismus
war sicher dabei,
wenn man betrachtet,
wie Herr Jenny aufgetreten ist.
Woran würden Sie das festmachen?
An seinen vier, fünf Punkten,
die St. Moritz besser machen könne.
Es sind zwar viele Anregungen, aber
dahinter stecken keine Lösungen.
Lösungen habe ich bisher
keine gehört von ihm.
Jetzt geben Jennys Gegner Gas,
schalten Inserate.
Die Lokalparteien schlagen sich
auf die Seite von Sigi Asprion.
Bis zum Schluss weiss niemand,
wer die Nase vorne haben wird.
Am Tag der Entscheidung
trifft sich Jenny mit dem
engsten Kreis in der Künstler-WG.
Erneutes Warten auf die SMS.
* Klingelton *
- Aha, jetzt wird es spannend.
Es ist da, ich habe es aber
noch nicht angeschaut.
Gut.
Ich zünde erst meine Zigarre an. Wir
machen es dramaturgisch richtig.
"Lieber Christian ..."
Ich zünde sie zuerst an.
Die Musik ist gut.
* Klassische Musik *
"Lieber Christian, lieber Sigi, hier
die Resultate vom zweiten Wahlgang."
"Christian: 894, Sigi: 822.
"Ich gratuliere Christian
herzlich ..."
* Jubel *
Bravo!
Super!
Grossartig! Ich gratuliere.
Du hast es geschafft.
Jetzt bauen wir eine Eishalle.
Ja, genau, komm, wir legen los!
Herr Jenny, sorry,
ich muss Sie kurz etwas fragen.
Was geht Ihnen durch den Kopf?
Ja, was es jetzt so zu tun gibt.
Ja, mal abklären.
Was man als Gemeindepräsident
genau machen muss?
Genau, aber ich kenne genug nette
Leute, die mir das erklären werden.
Ich habe es mir irgendwo notiert: Sie
sind u.a. zuständig fürs Militär ...
Das gibt es hier nicht.
... für die Polizei.
- Das ist okay.
Für die Polizei ist ja ein
anderes Vorstandsmitglied zuständig.
Wir werden es sehen.
Sagen wir es so:
Es sind gewisse Aufgaben,
die bisher nicht
in Ihrer Kernkompetenz waren.
Das ist so, aber sie werden jetzt
zu meiner Kernkompetenz.
Ich glaube, man muss
v.a. ein guter Generalist sein
und nicht alles im Detail kennen.
Und man muss
einen Überblick behalten
und v.a. wissen, wer es weiss.
Ich glaube, das kann ich schon.
Doch, doch.
Ah, jetzt ruft er an.
Sigi, guten Morgen.
Vielen Dank!
Vielen Dank -
auch für die Fairness und alles.
Das ist wirklich ...
Nein, noch nicht. Aber ich würde
dich gerne noch schnell sehen.
Könnten wir uns um 12.30 Uhr oder
13 Uhr oder so?
Die rufen sicher bald an.
Das man sich beim Gemeindehaus trifft?
Ist das gut?
Okay. Alles Liebe,
bis später, danke, Sigi.
Das ist nicht ganz einfach, oder?
- Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Das ist auch das, was mich immer
am meisten beschäftigt hatte.
Das ist Politik.
- Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Es ist menschlich
halt nicht ganz einfach.
Aber ja.
* Handyvibration *
Was am Anfang kaum jemand
gedacht hätte, ist passiert:
Ab dem 1. Januar 2019 steht Christian
Jenny an der Spitze von St. Moritz
und trägt die volle Verantwortung.
Ich frage nochmals
zum Schluss dieses Porträts:
Wie stark, glauben Sie, wird sich
Ihr Leben auf den Kopf stellen?
Machen Sie nochmals einen Film,
dann sehen wir es.
Das machen wir.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich enorm.
Aber ich mag Veränderungen.
Das Konstanteste in meinem Leben
waren schon immer die Veränderungen.
Und es ist bisher immer, immer,
immer gut herausgekommen.
Ich konnte immer
auf Veränderungen vertrauen.
Und ich vertraue jetzt
auch auf diese Veränderungen.